(Toilet flushing).
SIERRA: Toilets.
Out of sight, out of mind, until one can’t
be found.
But just like healthcare and nutrition, access
to a clean toilet has enormous health consequences.
More than a million people die every year
from diseases tied to poor sanitation, and
millions more suffer illness, stunting and
lifetime debilitations.
All told, fifty-five percent of the global
population lacks access to safe sanitation.
And for those trying to solve this problem,
the biggest barrier may not be funding, or
technology, but...culture.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters.
Today...toilets.
United Nations: November the 19th is World
Toilet Day.
TIME: The day aims to end the global sanitation
crisis.
United Nations: This is a situation for billions
of people around the world.
SIERRA: So, World Toilet Day is coming up
and the response to hearing that there is
a serious UN sponsored day for toilets might
make people laugh, or feel a little iffy on
discussing it.
So why would we need a day like that?
YAMAKOSHI: Well, what would you do if you
didn't have a toilet?
SIERRA: Fair point.
This is Brooke Yamakoshi.
She is a water, sanitation, and hygiene specialist
at the United Nations Children's Fund, also
known as UNICEF, based in New York.
She knows a lot about toilets.
YAMAKOSHI: I mean, the ability to manage our
bodily functions, and these things that we
frequently don't talk about, but are so core
to us, bodily functions of urination, defecation,
and for half the population, menstruation.
It's really at the core of our dignity.
It's also a foundation for health.
Without a toilet that contains waste, and
then separates it from people coming in contact
with that waste, we would all be exposed to
harmful pathogens that cause many different
illnesses and diseases.
And it doesn't stop at the toilet either.
So without waste being safely transported
away from our toilets and from our homes and
treated somewhere, we would all be surrounded
by wastewater in our neighborhoods and in
the environment.
SIERRA: So in terms of the numbers, can you
sort of give me a wide angle view of toilet
access as a global issue?
SLAYMAKER: Well there are three, main things
that we measure at the global level.
SIERRA: This is Tom Slaymaker.
He also focuses on global monitoring of drinking
water, sanitation, and hygiene at UNICEF headquarters
in New York.
He sees the big picture of how this plays
out around the world.
He spoke to us on a rainy day from London.
SLAYMAKER: So one is the population who practice
open defecation.
So that means they don't have any kind of
toilet at all and they just use, you know,
bushes, fields, beaches, or watercourses.
The other thing that we measure is the population
with a basic sanitation service.
So that means that they have some kind of
hygienic toilet that is not being shared with
other people, that's not shared with other
households.
And then the next level of service up is what
we call “safely managed sanitation.”
And that means that you not only have a hygienic
toilet, but you also have a mechanism in place
to ensure that the human waste that's produced
is then being treated and disposed of safely
before being discharged back into the environment.
SIERRA: And how many people fall into each
of these categories?
SLAYMAKER: So the global level, we still have
673 million people practicing open defecation.
There are about 2 billion people who still
lack even a basic level of service.
So that's one in four people worldwide.
And if you look at the population without
safe sanitation, that's more like 4.2 billion
people.
SIERRA: That is more than half the people
on earth.
And each of them runs the risk of getting
sick, every day.
Access to sanitation is a problem across the
globe - even in North America - but the problem
is particularly dire in parts of South Asia,
Southeast Asia and Sub-Saharan Africa.
It tends to be worse in poor areas with rapid
population growth.
SIERRA: Do we have an idea of how many people
die as a result of this problem?
SLAYMAKER: WHO have estimated that globally,
around 1.2 million deaths could have been
prevented through access to adequate drinking
water, sanitation, and hygiene.
The problem is particularly acute for young
children who are very vulnerable.
And so, I think we estimate there are around
300,000 children under five who die each year
as a result of not having basic water, sanitation
and hygiene facilities.
SIERRA: So when you look at a map, where do
you see this happening?
SLAYMAKER: Well, some regions and countries
have much further to go.
If you look at our data you'll see that particularly
Sub Saharan Africa, and Southern Asia, and
also Oceania, the Pacific, have much lower
levels of coverage of sanitation facilities.
And this is partly to do with different stages
of development.
These are mostly poorer countries.
But even if you move up the sanitation ladder,
and you start to look at issues of treatment
and disposal of waste, even in Europe and
North America, and in Australia and New Zealand,
we're still only at about three quarters of
the population that has this high level of
service.
So all countries have further to go in in
order to improve sanitation, but obviously
they’re all starting at different positions.
YAMAKOSHI: Even here in the US, there are
many people that still lack safe sanitation.
And that's not just toilets, but waste being
transported and treated safely away from their
household.
There were congressional briefings on this
just last year in 2019 and a great report
that came out on this called “Flushed and
Forgotten: Sanitation and Wastewater in Rural
Communities in the US,” and that deals with
all sorts of low income communities that tend
to be Black, Native American and Latinx, and
highlights a lot of the inequalities that
still exist even in our own country.
SIERRA: Do you think you can give me a sort
of run through of how a lack of toilet access
leads to disease transmission?
What kinds of disease?
What are people at risk of here?
YAMAKOSHI: Yeah, absolutely.
So there are a few different ways.
So first of all, I'll talk about the 673 million
people that don't have any type of toilet.
So for those people, their feces are just
in the environment where they live, where
they work, where their kids are playing, where
maybe they're farming or growing food for
their own consumption.
Feces in the environment can make it into
their homes, and eventually into their bodies,
through a couple of different pathways.
So one is through just normal human behavior,
it could be as simple as walking around outside
and then tracking that into your home.
Or it could be through the behavior of animals
may be doing the same thing, or even flies
that are going back and forth.
SLAYMAKER: But it's not just about whether
I've got a toilet, it's about whether my neighbors
have got a toilet, and what happens to the
waste from those toilets.
So clearly, once you flush, you can't just
forget about it.
You want to be reassured that that waste is
going somewhere, and that it's going to be
treated, and it's not going to just be flushed
into the street, or into someone else's backyard,
or into a slum where somebody else's kids
are going to come into contact with the waste.
YAMAKOSHI: Now just a quick run through of
the different diseases that you can get from
not having a toilet.
So, the big one is diarrhea.
This is a major public health concern.
It's, I believe, the second biggest killer
of children under five.
And this category of diarrheal diseases includes
cholera, which is an acute diarrheal disease
that can kill within hours.
So, a really big concern.
But then there are other neglected tropical
diseases.
So, these are things like worms and trachoma
that can cause a significant burden of disease
globally, as well as vector borne diseases
that are things you've heard of like West
Nile Virus that have a more indirect pathway
through sanitation that can facilitate the
breeding of these mosquitoes.
You know, really critically for UNICEF, poor
sanitation can lead to malnutrition and stunting,
which is something that can lead to poor physical
and cognitive development of kids and affect
them throughout their entire life.
And there's other things that you've probably
heard of becoming a bigger concern globally,
like antimicrobial resistance.
So poor sanitation can increase the risk of
these preventable infections that we then
treat with antibiotics.
And then, you know, we are excreting these
sort of organisms into the environment.
So, that's just kind of a run through of some
of the diseases that a lack of toilets can
cause.
SIERRA: Sickness and death are only the primary
consequences when people don’t have clean
toilet access.
Those of you who caught our episode on antibiotic
resistant bacteria know how serious this problem
can be, and that it doesn’t stay in one
place for very long.
And lack of clean and safe toilet access can
also lead to serious and long-term social
issues.
SLAYMAKER: If you don't have basic sanitation
facilities in schools, then it's very difficult
to educate children.
And if you don't have them in healthcare facilities,
then you can get lots of unintended infections,
while you're at that health care facility.
But it also goes beyond that, I think.
We would also say that it's about dignity,
and it's about human rights.
YAMAKOSHI: Lack of a toilet can expose women
and girls in particular, although really all
people to sexual, psychological or physical
abuse or violence.
And I mean, it's really important to note
that even just the perceived threat of violence
or harassment can cause stress.
And we all know that just from having to try
to find a public toilet in a park after dark,
for instance, those of us that live in the
US.
And this can cause women and children in particular
to not go outside to use a toilet and to engage
in other sorts of behaviors that could be
risky for their health, like holding it or
maybe defecating or urinating in a bucket
until they can empty that outside.
Lack of toilets can dissuade women from participating
in the labor force and this has serious consequences
for all of society and for a country's economic
development.
If there aren't toilets in in office buildings,
workplaces, markets, then women may not choose
to work there or may have to cut their hours
short or may miss work on certain days of
the month for instance, if they're menstruating,
or days of the week if there's something that's
making them specifically ill.
So this has a cost for all of society.
It's not just about those specific women and
children.
It's something that prevents us as a whole
society from moving forward.
SLAYMAKER: Sanitation is really a sort of
key driver of economic productivity and a
driver of development.
So I think, historically, Europe and North
America have made dramatic progress in economic
productivity, following improvements in sanitation.
YAMAKOSHI: So because of this, sanitation
is recognized as a human right and there is
actually a UN General Assembly resolution
on the human right to sanitation, which entitles
everyone to “a physical and affordable access
to sanitation in all spheres of life that
is safe, hygienic, secure, and socially and
culturally acceptable, and that provides privacy
and ensures dignity.”
This link between human rights and sanitation
has been made by many who we recognize as
human rights champions throughout history.
So this is people like, you know, Mahatma
Gandhi, Nelson Mandela, but also Martin Luther
King, Jr.
SIERRA: Okay so we get how important safe
sanitation is for health, quality of life,
and economic growth.
But as we discussed at the top of the episode,
solving the problem isn’t as simple as coming
into an area, installing a few hundred toilets,
and leaving.
The process of changing people's habits is
far more complicated.
YAMAKOSHI: Sanitation or using a toilet is
a behavioral pattern that many of us have
established over many years.
So ensuring that everybody, everywhere has
access to safe sanitation is about a few different
things.
It's not just the toilet, although the toilet
and the supply is one important component.
It's about the behavior, and it's also about
the government policies and the sort of way
that government can enable sanitation to be
provided to everyone and the view that government
takes on sanitation being a public good.
It's really critical for first time users
of sanitation to do two things that are related
to norms.
The first is to abandon a longstanding norm
of open defecation.
And then it also calls on people to create
a new norm, and that new norm is of consistent
toilet use.
And that can also be challenging, because,
again, this comes back to that it's not only
about the behavior, depending on the type
of facilities that you end up constructing
for yourself, they could be more comfortable
and more desirable than other types of facilities.
So it's really important to see how the facilities
can reinforce the behavior.
And the behavior, obviously being at the center
of what it would take to get everybody to
be able to use a toilet for the first time
everywhere.
SLAYMAKER: It's about changing social norms
around sanitation.
And making it no longer acceptable to practice
open defecation, and generating an awareness
of the risks associated with unsafe sanitation,
and a sense of pride in having a clean village
or a clean community or clean country that
other people might want to visit and and invest
in.
But the drivers or the incentives, I think,
vary widely.
So in some countries, you find that, you know,
the main driver is around health, concerns
about health, but in others, it might be around
aspirations of modernity.
So, you really have to understand what is
going to motivate people to act and to invest
their own money, but also to work with others
to try and solve the problem.
SIERRA: We’re going to take a quick break,
but when we get back we’re going to talk
about India - a country that still accounts
for half of the world’s open defecation.
Hello listeners!
So if you dig all the questions we ask in
Why It Matters, you are going to love this
other podcast brought to you by our friends
over at Pushkin Industries.
It’s called Solvable.
Kind of a natural fit.
Solvable is a weekly podcast where Malcolm
Gladwell, Anne Applebaum, and Jacob Weisberg
ask how we can find solutions to some of the
biggest issues of our time.
You’ll hear from David Baltimore on AIDS,
Sal Khan on basic education, and Roseanne
Hagerty on homelessness.
These problems can seem too big or too complicated
to fix.
But in the hands of the right people -- activists,
scientists, policymakers and politicians at
the top of their fields -- there are ways
to solve them.
And that’s the hopeful message of Solvable.
Listen and subscribe now in your favorite
podcasting app.
When it comes to toilets, the spotlight often
falls on India.
According to 2017 statistics from the World
Health Organization and UNICEF, over 542 million
Indians lack basic sanitation, and 345 million
still practice open defecation.
The health effects are devastating, including
disease, death, and lifetime debilitations.
The last of these has been described as one
of the largest losses of human potential in
history.
India’s problem is not only big, but particularly
hard to solve.
And that’s because the country’s sanitation
habits are tied to religious and cultural
beliefs that have existed for thousands of
years.
VYAS: You can't really talk about open defecation
without talking about India.
More than half of rural Indians still go in
the open based on the most recent credible
estimates of you know, where people poop.
SIERRA: This is Sangita Vyas.
She’s a researcher that focuses on environmental
risks to child health in India.
VYAS: So, to understand why open defecation
persists we have to sort of understand a little
bit about how people think about purity and
pollution in India.
So why is this important for sanitation?
Well, it's because these ideas of purity and
pollution map on to the caste system.
So, what is caste?
Well, caste has its roots in Hinduism and
it's basically a social hierarchy.
It's something that you're born into.
You can't change caste much like you can't
change race.
Now, higher caste people are seen to be more
pure than lower caste people and people from
the very lowest castes, which historically
were called Untouchables and now they are
called Dalits, they are seen to be permanently
polluted and unfortunately they are extremely
marginalized and oppressed in Indian society
even today.
Now, the Dalit community they have traditionally
been responsible for doing the work called
manual scavenging.
This is the daily cleaning of feces from a
dry toilet.
And because people from this particular caste
had to do this work, were compelled to do
this work, they were seen as polluted by this
work.
SIERRA: Over time, as opportunities have slowly
grown, members of the Dalit caste have become
less willing to carry out this work.
This means that many Indians in rural communities
have been left to clean their own latrines.
If the act of emptying your latrine would
cause you to become untouchable within the
caste system, chances are you’d avoid doing
it.
As a result, large pit latrines and open defecation
are seen as good alternatives.
Yet, exposure to waste is causing Indians,
and particularly Indian children, incredible
harm, including mental and physical damage
that will remain with them all their lives.
Of these non-lethal effects, the most dramatic
is stunting, which affects some 65 million
Indian children under the age of five.
It has been described as one of the largest
losses of human potential in history.
It’s a problem that the Indian government
has tried to address.
VYAS: So the Indian government started this
campaign in 2014.
And the goal was to eliminate open defecation
in a five year timeframe.
And the vast majority of that work and the
money spent on this campaign went towards
latrine construction.
Now what I've just told you about is that
it's much less about economic status and having
the money to construct a toilet.
It's much more about attitudes and norms and
beliefs that really promote open defecation
and prevent people from wanting to use the
latrine.
So, you would think that, well, maybe it needs
to be more about promotional campaigns to
try to convince people that going in the latrine
is good and pure and doesn't create challenges
for observing purity.
And unfortunately, that wasn't really what
was focused on in the campaign, in the government
campaign.
So it was just much more about construction,
much less about convincing people that using
a latrine is a good thing.
And that there are ways to empty the latrine
that don't pose challenges for observing purity,
and things like that.
SIERRA: India’s ruling party claims to have
constructed more than 110 million toilets
as part of this effort, and made them accessible
to 600 million people.
And while this number is impressive, Sangita
and other researchers believe there is still
a great amount of work to be done, not only
to maintain these facilities, but also in
the field of education.
VYAS: So, the government very much believes
that this program was successful and that
there's not really a need to keep doing this
government campaign anymore.
The political will to work on sanitation is
now over.
Does open defecation still persist?
Yes, it does.
A number of studies that include work that
my colleagues and I have done, include work
that other researchers and teams have done,
really show that many people still defecate
in the open and that the problem is far from
being solved.
Our research also shows that many households
now have a latrine.
And so the Swachh Bharat mission really did
seem to actually succeed in getting households
to construct latrines.
But there's still a barrier in terms of people
using the latrine.
You know, these are beliefs that have been
held for a very long time.
They are deeply ingrained and they're kind
of similar to race in America.
I think that solving the sanitation problem
in India would require really attacking caste,
really attacking untouchability.
And if people didn't believe in untouchability
or didn't believe in purity anymore, then
they wouldn't mind using the toilet, but it's
gonna be really tough to get people to not
believe in purity anymore.
SIERRA: Open defecation is a public health
issue that holds India back even as the country
grows in so many other ways.
Breaking old cultural barriers is a slow,
difficult task.
But that doesn’t mean that the experts who
have dedicated their lives to fixing this
problem are giving up.
Even as challenges like India loom large,
there have also been success cases.
YAMAKOSHI: Eliminating open defecation by
2030, which is the year that the global community
has marked as the target for getting this
done, will require a massive acceleration
in toilet use and a massive acceleration beyond
the rate at which we've been progressing.
One of the key factors in rapid progress all
over the world, where we've seen societies
achieve near total sanitation in a generation
is strong government leadership.
Strong government leadership that prioritizes
sanitation and celebrates things like World
Toilet Day, despite it perhaps sounding a
little bit funny.
So maybe just looking back to the 1960s and
the 1970s, there were four countries in East
Asia, and those were Singapore, Thailand,
South Korea and Malaysia.
And they were able to produce really remarkable
results in a generation.
And the interesting thing about those countries
is that while now we think of them as being
wealthy countries, at the time, the per capita
income levels in those East Asian states were
equivalent to the income levels of many Sub
Saharan African countries today.
So that just shows that even in a resource
constrained environment, you can make a lot
of progress.
Since 2000, there are a couple of states that
have made rapid progress in eliminating open
defecation or reducing open defecation to
much lower levels.
So Ethiopia, Cambodia, both of those countries
reduced open defecation by more than 50 percentage
points.
And then there are other countries like Laos,
Nepal and Indonesia, that have been able to
increase the use of toilets to more than 40
percentage points and those are decent toilets
that are separating waste from human contact.
And to highlight another country that is a
low income country is Burkina Faso.
Since 2000, Burkina Faso has reduced open
defecation by 25 percentage points, which
is really incredible.
SIERRA: Experts agree that strong, sustained
support from the government is an essential
factor in solving the problem.
But when it comes to the nuts and bolts, there
is no single message or technique that will
work on a global scale.
And that’s because the cultural and behavioral
challenges are different depending on where
you are.
SLAYMAKER: A lot depends on, you know, the
way people are living, the type of housing
they have.
Whether they're living in urban areas or rural
areas.
So really, it's very important to have that
local knowledge and that's why having country
offices who are very embedded in the local
culture and in the local economy, trying to
figure out what is going to be the best combination
of interventions in order to move things forward
on the ground.
SIERRA: I just find myself learning so much
from this conversation and it makes me wonder
if there's enough global awareness about this
problem?
SLAYMAKER: Well, I think for those of us who
work on it, we do get frustrated that it's
not taken more seriously or or given more
political attention.
I think one of the things we find is that
the first thing that a politician will notice
when they visit a community or visit a country
is the sanitation facilities.
If the toilets are in a terrible condition,
they'll complain but it's also the first thing
that they forget when they leave, and they
get in the car, or they get in the plane and
go away.
And I think one of the reasons for that is
that, you know, sanitation is just not a very
sexy topic.
And so, politicians would much prefer to be
opening a school or opening a new health care
facility than cutting the ribbon on a new
fecal sludge treatment facility, for example.
But there all, you know, examples of where
governments have really stepped up and shown
leadership and recognized the importance of
the issue, and it shows that it can be done.
SIERRA: When we think of things someone needs
in order to have a chance at a decent life,
we think of food, education, healthcare, freedom.
It’s strange at first to add the word “toilet”
to the list, but, you know, the more you think
about it, and the more you consider the consequences,
toilets really do emerge as a basic human
need.
The desire to end death and disease due to
poor sanitation is reason enough to solve
the problem.
But it’s also not the only reason.
The health effects for those who lack toilet
access can easily spill over to the rest of
the world’s population, through resurgent
diseases and antibiotic resistant bacteria.
Lack of access also slows development and
harms innovation in countries like India with
which the United States needs strong strategic
partnerships.
As mundane as they seem, toilets are simply
a key part of developing a fair, peaceful,
and prosperous world.
And yet for all that,they are rarely front
and center when people talk about global health.
And that has to change.
SIERRA: So.
If you could say one thing to someone who
has never thought about this issue before,
what would it be?
YAMAKOSHI: That's a really good question.
I would say that just because you have sanitation,
it doesn't mean that you're safe.
It's not enough for it to just be you.
Sanitation is a public good.
It requires everyone to have it.
It requires your neighbor to have it for your
own health.
It requires all of society to have it for
a country to be able to develop.
I know that these notions of modernity and
using the word “modern” can sometimes
be loaded, but I would challenge you to name
one country that you think of as being advanced
or modern that doesn't have universal access
to safe sanitation.
In that way, sanitation is a solution.
It can help to achieve all of these other
goals.
Goals in health, in gender equality, poverty
eradication, education, having clean environments,
and food security, and so many more other
goals that I'm forgetting.
So if we want to live in these clean and healthy
homes for ourselves, if we want our children
to go to schools that are safe and healthy
learning environments, if we want to go to
the hospital, and be able to relieve ourselves
inside, we need to give this issue priority.
And the last thing I'll say about this is
sanitation is really a no regrets investment.
I would really challenge all of us to find
one government or one individual person that
invested in sanitation and regretted it.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Want to just say hello?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you like the show, you are very much
encouraged to leave us a review!
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria and our
intern is Senniah Mason.
Teagan Judd and Makenzie Drukker provided
us with extra support on this episode.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!